WESLEY CHUN: Greetings, 18th
century American colonists
and modern day
software developers.
This is Wesley George
Washington Chun from Google.
In this video, we're
going to demo the Gmail
API with real code,
but we'll also
discuss early America,
connecting you
to past and present revolutions.
When email was
invented, rules were
needed to govern access to it.
Protocols were used to send,
route, and receive email
on the internet.
Similarly, when the
United States was created,
the founding
fathers had to craft
rules for a new
government, calling it
the Articles of Confederation.
However, neither of those
articles nor email protocols
were able to keep up with
the growth of a new country
or advancements in email
features and usage.
Let's start with email.
With internet
protocols, developers
work at the message level,
sending and downloading them,
whether for a web or mobile app.
The problem is that
email has grown
in ways that no one thought of.
Features such as drafts,
labels, and threads
weren't even considered
back in the early days,
but now have become
a crucial backbone
to the email experience.
Dealing only with messages
doesn't work anymore.
So that's why we
created the Gmail API.
Besides basic message management
and granular access control,
the API can process drafts,
threads, labels, and folders,
as well as perform
admin functionality,
such as mass user migration
all without needing
to write lower level
code such as raw sockets
with internet protocols.
Google users also expect search,
so the API has got that too.
Check out the clip from
the Gmail API launch video
to get an idea of what kind
of queries you can perform.
All right.
Enough talk.
Time the code.
We'll reuse the same
authorized API access code
covered in an earlier episode.
So check out that via over the
first link before continuing .
If you're completely
new to Google APIs,
you should review
the earlier episode
found at the second link.
We'll pause now to let you
catch up before coming back
to join me here.
All caught up?
Great.
Now let's say I wanted
to archive the busiest
threads in my Gmail account
that subscribe to many mailing
lists.
I'm curious about which big
things happen to make everyone
engage and reply.
To kick off such a project,
let's create a simple command
line script that
looks for threads
with more than two
messages in them
and displays the subject
line as well as the number
of messages in those threads.
Ready?
Let's go to the computer.
Ready to start coding?
We'll do this demo in Python,
but the purpose of the code is
not necessarily to target just
Python developers as the Google
APIs client library is available
for Java, JavaScript, .NET,
Objective C, PHP, Dart,
GO, Node.js, and Ruby.
So regardless of which
language you use,
the calls will be quite similar.
Google's REST APIs
are web based,
so they'll work with server
side apps including command line
scripts like the one
we're building here.
The calls for native mobile
libraries, such as for Android
and iOS when available, will
also be named similarly.
The bottom line is that if
you're not a Python server side
dev, consider this as
pseudocode to help guide you.
All right, so after
the standard Python
imports on the first
few lines, on line five
is the scope for
read-only access to Gmail.
Yes, the API supports a variety
of specific granular access
unlike internet email protocols.
In this particular
demo, we're only
going to look at threads so
read only is good enough.
And the rest of the code
that you see below here
is the standard common
authorized API access boiler
plate that we covered
in an earlier episode.
So go back and review
that video if you
need to go over it again.
On line 13, we have
something more specific.
This is where we built the Gmail
service endpoint, by passing
in Gmail, and the API
Ike version, which
is B1 that you see there.
And then on the next
line we're going
to call users.thread.list
to get a user's threads.
In particular, I want
to get my threads,
so that's where you
see user ID is me.
But if you want to do a
query, a specific query
like all messages from a
particular user with a subject
line or with a label,
that's where you enter it
also on the same line here.
But in this example, we're
just going to get all threads.
So we're going to pull
this out right now.
Once you're done, call execute.
And then you get
back a JSON payload.
It comes back as a
Python dictionary.
The thing we care about
are all the threads.
And that's given the
key threads here.
For some reason, if you
don't have any threads,
we're going to hedge our bets
and pass in an empty list
just in case, because
on the next few lines,
you can see we're going to
have a for loop that goes
through every single thread.
And what we're
going to do is we're
going to look for all
threads have at least
three messages in that thread.
So we're going to call the Get
method with a specific thread
ID.
And what we're going
to do there is we're
going to check hey, how many
messages are in this thread,
because we really care about it.
If you don't get enough,
we're going to dump ya.
So line 17 makes
the call to Get.
Line 18 grabs the count
of the number of messages.
And then the next block of
code, as you can probably guess,
is going to start with an
if statement that says, hey,
if I don't have at
least three messages,
I'm going to drop you.
And that's on line 20.
Once we know there's at
least three messages,
we're going to go down into
the first message, which is
at index zero we can see there.
We're going to grab
its payload, and we're
going to take a look
at the subject lines,
because we only care
about messages that
have subject lines in
them or threads that
have subject lines in them.
So we're just going to grab
it from the first message.
So let's set our default
subject to empty first.
And then what we're
going to do is
we're going to cycle
through all of the headers
in this message looking
for a subject line.
And if there is one, save it
and break out of the loop.
And then on the last
two lines of code,
we're going to check, hey,
do I got a subject line?
If so, print it.
And also tell me how many
messages are in this thread,
because that's
what we care about.
All right.
Looking good?
Great.
Let's give it a shot.
All right.
So here we go.
It shouldn't take too long.
As you can tell this
is the email address
I use for a mailing list.
And that's it.
Isn't that awesome?
Wow.
The demo code
filtered out threads
with fewer than three messages.
You could easily change that
threshold to 50 or a 100
should you be on very
busy mailing lists.
But wasn't that
example nice and short?
Before the Gmail API, I
had to write a lower level
code, including raw TCP
sockets, logging into a server,
and be intimately familiar with
talking to an email protocol
by sending and
receiving strings.
Using your favorite dev
tools and talking to an API
is one way that we can better
adapt to developers needs
today.
To find out more
about the Gmail API,
check out the docs
via the first link.
If you're an email sender,
whether you use the API or not,
strongly consider
embedding markup
in your messages to provide
for a better user experience.
The second link talks
more about that.
Finally, you can
access other episodes
in this and other series with
the links down at the bottom.
This is Wesley Chun
from Google, and I'll
see you next-- no wait.
This is George Washington, and
I didn't finish my story yet.
So the Articles of
Confederation didn't
provide for what was needed?
What was it replaced by?
Well, Congress and
other key stakeholders
were pretty hard to come up with
USA V2 called The Constitution.
Now it may not look
like much, but trust me
it's way better than
what we had before.
V2 was launched in 1789 when
I was elected president.
And the rest is history.
But wait.
There's one more thing.
The war ended in 1781, but I
didn't get elected till 1789.
So who led the country in
those eight years in between?
Well, the Articles
of Confederation
stipulated presidents
elected for one year terms.
So the first president
was actually John Hanson.
I even wrote a letter
congratulating him
on his election.
Yep.
You can tell all your
friends that I'm actually
the nice president.
But since the
Constitution became
the current legitimate
form of our government,
got to dish out the tough
love to my compatriot.
Sorry dude.
Hope you learned
something today.
Thanks for tuning in to this
episode where we introduced you
to the next revolution in
programmatic email access
as well as get a short
American history lesson.
George and John are
now gone, but I'll
see you on the next episode
of the "Launch Pad Online."